now to that potential deal to raise
america's debt ceiling for now senate
majority leader chuck schumer is
considering an offer from minority
leader mitch mcconnell it could prevent
economic chaos for now but set up
another fight in december ed o'keefe is
at the white house ed good morning good
morning nate you know i'm sure you've
done it i do it every once in a while
you hit the snooze button to delay the
inevitable before you get out of bed
well look that's what congress is doing
right now and delaying the inevitable
fight over the debt limit by a few extra
weeks at this point overnight senate
majority leader chuck schumer as you
said signaled they're on the verge of a
deal
we're making good progress we're not
there yet but i hope we can come to an
agreement tomorrow morning
overnight amid another standoff over the
nation's debt democrats signaled they're
likely to accept republican leader mitch
mcconnell's concession a plan to extend
the nation's borrowing limit into early
december some democrats were relieved it
is
a short-term
solution and hopefully republicans will
be more reasonable
in the next couple of months while
others didn't buy what's my reaction to
his so-called offer just what i said
it's bs he should stop playing games get
out of the way so that the 50 democrats
can
avoid
what would be an economic catastrophe
the debt limit's been raised about 80
times since the 1960s in order to pay
off the nation's bills the treasury
department says it needs to happen again
by october 18th and failure to do so
could put the nation's credit rating at
risk send stocks tumbling and delay
social security payments
at the white house president biden met
with top bank ceos who agreed that the
partisan brinksmanship needs to stop the
united states pays its bills
it's who we are this shouldn't be
partisan we should never even get this
close there are huge economic costs
already being born by companies and
lawyers trying to figure out what this
means if something like this ever
happens
so white house aides warned that
mcconnell's offer only means that
they're going to have to do a
longer-term extension of the debt closer
to the end of the year and they may have
to use those tricky senate procedural
tactics to get it done meanwhile all of
this happening while here at the white
house they're looking at new poll
numbers that show the president's
approval rating sitting at 38 percent
the lowest yet of his presidency tony
all right ed thank you very much